welcome to this video playing esteros or
south korea right don't see that often I
cannot remember ever play someone from
Korea if this is the right term this is
the right flag you can you can choose
freely there so it's a in some cases you
just have the the right flag because
it's um you can also touch just attach
it to the IP address range so you're
basically getting them the location of
the guy where this way is connecting
from or you can I'm a sign of lag to
your liking this is why you see those
kind of yeah let's say what do you have
under arctica and things like that or
some exotic places so it might be
someone from South Korea but also could
be from somewhere else ok we have a
regos in Queens gambit their plate this
quickly no need to spend much time there
provoke the knight to c6
yeah a six now is mostly played to
prevent any night jumps to be five in
case of Bishop t6 and now I have 95 I'm
gladly getting rid of this Bishop down
yep that's good so let's go b4 b5 yeah I
know this kind of structure well so it's
it's no use in and spending too much
time maybe be 5a be queen bee five here
and checking directly on the queenside
v6s Roxy 6 so you cannot do that ok
let's push the a pawn I have a little
bit of pressure on the queenside it's
it's nothing super serious but it's um
it's still useful to have ok
interesting maybe night up here so maybe
93 c 5 as a possibility okay so where do
I go with the Queen to before maybe yeah
setting up this it's not a pin but
almost it couldn't it can become serious
like a six is a move now Oh interesting
what about a six isn't this good what is
he doing against that pawn takes Knight
c6 is winning so a 95 de 5 and then a
seven is also winning then threatening a
seven it's just serious yeah the
spinning situation proved to be a
problem maybe I could have played look
c6 even here maybe even a success is
certainly strong ok so what am i doing
um I can take with the pawn simply I
just that is a simple one but but a good
one mm just attacking luck Reese I still
threatening a seven zone yep that was
good I think looked like an okay game
yeah up to here I think we are this is
this is a theoretical position and black
normally goes a six the idea is to play
Bishop d6 but without allowing 95 so he
wants to keep his Bishop he went there
immediately so I gladly took this now
march up the pawn yeah ok the the only
thing is that here of course I can try
to
delay this a little bit this b5 like
queen bee three and then a 45 maybe this
better it's possible but okay I was I
wanted to play the plate quickly so why
not and I keep I keep an initiative him
quite clearly like is under pressure he
has no serious counter play like here
and 95 is also good yeah why not
centralizing the peace and c6 and that's
it's already difficult to play in after
a six it's it's over computer wants to
play Bishop f5 and after a six it wants
to play this position no it says this is
rotten right I'm just winning the a pawn
them it's very close to a technical win
really now it's already very problematic
at here is lost this just lost this is
this loses loses much much of his
material most of his material yeah at 95
I just take a tempo on the rook and then
a seven is a touchdown for the a pawn
quite quite funny okay it was a fun game
okay well thanks for watching